blockchain cruises on YouTube crypto
raves in Miami
multi-million dollar Super Bowl
commercials fortune favors the brave
for a while wherever you looked the
crypto crowd was on top of the world
but the party is over
the market value tank you saw a series
of crashes as alleged fraud dominates
headlines Sam bankman freed arrested at
the request of the U.S government and
Regulators cracked down
the financial Revolution crypto once
promised looks further away than ever 25
out of 45 of the world's biggest
economies have either completely or
partially banned crypto
but crypto's future might have less to
do with money than you think some
believe it could hold the key to a
wholesale transformation of the internet
cryptocurrency was really the first step
in this journey I think we're just just
about to see that bit whether it starts
to get interesting
in the 1990s people started to worry
about how a new invention the internet
would affect people's privacy these
anxieties gave birth to a movement to
combat them the cypherpunks we believe
in personal privacy for everybody
their distrust of governments and
corporations made headlines
as open source code and file sharing
went mainstream the cypherpunks were
looking for a peer-to-peer network not
for music or movies but for money
I created an entire movement and
community of people who decided to
dedicate their lives to working on this
technology to try to build privacy
preserving technology and secure
Communications and the cryptocurrency
movement followed directly out of that
the ambition was to develop a secure and
irreversible payment system that didn't
involve centralized Banks corporations
or governments
privacy issues are inherent to the
financial system if you use a financial
app they're going to have to verify your
identity if you want to operate in a
fully private way no one knows who you
are you can't do that in most parts of
the world anymore if you're transacting
online it's just not possible and so
that's a big part of the motivation for
cryptocurrencies is people want to be
able to operate in a permissionless way
in 2008 an email from an anonymous
person or persons calling themselves
Satoshi Nakamoto appeared to hold the
answer to this challenge
Satoshi Nakamoto created the world's
first cryptocurrency a digital form of
money Bitcoin
the project took off and despite wild
swings the value of Bitcoin has grown as
has the industry
there are tens of thousands of
cryptocurrencies now people in the space
like to call it permissionless you don't
have to get the rubber stamp of a
regulator to create one
it's been a wild ride by the start of
2020 crypto's market capitalization had
reached 250 billion dollars
by the end of 2021 it had swollen to
three trillion dollars
before falling to 828 billion by 2023
it's a volatile investment
so what's the attraction of crypto the
answer partly lies in the technology
that makes cryptocurrencies work the
blockchain
so if you want to create a
cryptocurrency you need some kind of way
of making sure no one fudges with it and
so that's why cryptocurrencies use
what's called a blockchain
the blockchain is a decentralized
digital Ledger
the key thing that's interesting about
them is they have what are called
consensus algorithms so ways in which
the different parties maintain the
blockchain agree on what is the source
of Truth
a majority of users verifies each
transaction on the blockchain they all
have an economic incentive to maintain
trust in the network so everyone acts
honestly because it's in their best
interests it means people can bypass
Central systems like Banks and
governments some would call it
revolutionary
to learn more about how the Bitcoin
blockchain Works click on the link
this has a lot of political implications
of course if you're able to transact
online without worrying about government
interference then of course you're
reducing the power of the government to
you know surveil the economy to control
people's lives that Vision I think is
very powerful to a lot of people
but now many fear the cypherpunk's
revolution is in jeopardy there
definitely is a lot of reflection
happening in the cryptocurrency
community right now a lot of people
thinking about what are the use cases
that are really going to drive adoption
where is it really going to make the
biggest impact
the answer might lie far from the
Financial Centers of the rich world
Nigeria is the world's second largest
user
now the first crypto unicorn in Latin
America bitcoin's price hits new record
high in Argentina
Africa Latin America and parts of Asia
have all seen rapid uptick of
cryptocurrencies in recent years their
stories might offer a glimpse of
crypto's future
crypto tends to be used more in places
where the alternatives are are worse so
for example you know if you look at
parts of the world like Argentina which
you know has hyperinflation doesn't have
a great score of value that's cheap and
inclusive for for people to transact
with you know crypto is in stable coins
in particular are used more often but
then other parts of the world you might
not see crypto as as useful
that's because transaction fees and the
price of moving money in and out of
crypto can make it a more expensive
option than transferring money in more
mainstream ways
countries like India once they create
really good retail payment systems that
are you know free account to count
transfers you know the the use case of
crypto goes down a lot because you have
a pretty good digital Financial system
anyway so why use crypto
one way of reducing these costs is
so-called layer 2 Solutions where
transactions happen on a framework built
on top of the main blockchain because
they don't need to be verified by as
many users transaction costs are lower
layer twos work pretty differently so
um they're probably going to be faster
than the core blockchains but there are
limits to what they can do I don't know
if they can handle everyone in the world
wanting to transact really frequently
for example
but the real Leap Forward for crypto
could be using the technology behind it
to build something much bigger we're in
the post money year of blockchains this
new layer is the social layer that's
building on this infrastructure it's
like building a new Digital Society
hi I'm Matthew favas The Economist
Finance correspondent if you're enjoying
watching this film you might be
interested to know that economy
subscribers get access to wealth of
global analysis on every accountable
topic you can read it you can listen to
it you can even be part of it at live
webinars for the best deals on
subscriptions click on the link and now
on with the film
in the quest to find the next
incarnation of cryptocurrencies some
believe the blockchain Technologies
behind them could end up fueling a whole
new version of the internet
this vision is called web3 and the big
difference between web 2 and web 3 is
who controls people's data and who
controls the various applications that
are running on the internet with web3
the idea is your information is stored
on the blockchain which is
permissionless decentralized and you
have ownership over it using your
identification credentials or so forth
the consequences for the majority of web
users could be profound
when you use a website like Facebook or
Instagram your data is collected and
owned by those companies it's how they
make their money in web 3 your data is
stored in a wallet on the blockchain
which only you have a key to you'd
interact with websites and apps on web3
through your wallet and when you log off
they can't see your data anymore seeing
as you own your data you might even be
able to make money from it
in theory web 2 companies could do this
if they chose to but advocates for web 3
believe a new decentralized internet
would make it far easier
[Music]
a lot of The Advocates and proponents
for web 3 aim to bring
incentives into the applications that
they're building so they aim to bring
the idea of paying for services directly
as opposed to paying using advertising
or behavioral data into a service and
also really creating incentive systems
where people can pool their funds
together and invest in the growth of a
protocol
the idea is a more democratic internet
fueled by the technology behind crypto
but this carries its own security risks
something that's important to remember
is the way that blockchains operate is
that all of the data on the blockchain
is available to everyone in the
blockchain network and for really public
permissionless decentralized networks
that means that data is public to
everyone in the world they are what we
call pseudonymous so you know you won't
see necessarily people's names or you
know identifying information you'll see
a random number but that data can still
be linked across transactions you can
still glean a lot of information from
that
and because blockchains have no Central
Authority no one would be responsible if
hackers did gain access to your data
the desires of these sisters really have
to think about how do you bake in
security at the very core knowing that
you're going to have an open system
which anyone can join how do you sort of
set the scales up how do you set the
protocol up so that it's hard for an
attacker to um to cause problems but
this is an incredibly important area of
research that we're still developing
which is really understanding the
economic security of these systems
if these lingering privacy issues can be
fixed crypto's future might not lie in
finance at all but in the next iteration
of the internet
there's a large part of the the crypto
Community that's very very driven by
ideology by ideals they have a vision
for a decentralized open internet where
anyone can spin up an application
contribute to it and you know be
rewarded
[Music]
[Applause]
all new technologies when they first
start uh can be clunky can be slow can
have problems and might not be anywhere
near as close to the technology that
they're trying to replace but what we
have to remember is that technology is
not a static thing it is constantly
changing and evolving and people are
working and so just because something is
slow today doesn't mean that it's going
to be slow tomorrow
thanks for watching if you want to read
more about cryptocurrencies or the
future of money click on the link below
and don't forget to subscribe
[Music]